やあ　みんな
今日はですねぇ
今、すっごい
中途半端な・・・色なんですよ
そう、ﾁｮｯﾄ茶色みたいな感じなんで
僕はもうね、ホントに
言っちゃあ、アレなんですけど
大学生活が、長くない
何の仕事に就くか解らないけど、きっとねぇ
いや、分んないけどね？
そんな、もう、激しい色にはできないと思うんだよね
職種によるかも知れないんですけど
なのでね？
ここはバシッとね、ちょっとね
もうﾁｮｲ明るくして、大学生活を締めくくろうかなと思いまして
新色のベビーレオで髪の毛を染めるよ？
どんな色になるかわかんない
色の変化を見ててください。今こんな色です。
覚えて、みんな覚えて！
覚えたね？
覚えたね？もう見せないよ？先生、先生もうヒントあげないから
さて、行きますよ
僕でも体そんなに黒くないっしょ？
黒くないんですけど…なんか顔がね？多分…
やっぱ、ちゃんと大学行ってるから日焼けするんですよね
あんまり白くない人には黒髪は似合わないって言う僕の中の勝手な妄想があってですね
もう全然なんか最近
髪型、色とか･･･
こぼれた！
まあ、何とかなるでしょう！
もう、アタマに来た！
俺はもう完全に今　ふっキレたぞ
反則でしょう？あそこで飛び出すとか、
もう！原液のまま着けてやる
奥さんね、原液つけるからね
もう、アタマに来たなあ
もう！イライラする
更年期障害
と言う訳で　一通り染め終わったんで
時間を置いて、洗い流して、乾かした所からスタートです
はい、染めました
え？これひょっとして？
どうですか？色的なあれは
ちょっと  わかんないと思うんですけど  結構
ほら、そしてなんかブリーチしたら髪の毛が
良い具合にパサパサして
これ僕何も、ワックスも何もしてないんですよ
デフォルトで、これですよ
そんな、明るくもないし、暗くもないって言うか
倉木麻衣って感じです
伝わるかな？
伝わらないよね？
こんな感じです
あ、これ分りやすいかもしれない
さっきと比べてもやっぱ、ちょっと
明るいんですよ
ギャッツビーのベビーレオ
なかなか  いい感じなので、ぜひ、染めてみてください
じゃな